hi there
hi
how are you
i'm good how are you i am very well i
appreciate you talking to me about this
i thought you were just terrific in it
and seeing you and your daughter
together was just really tremendous to
watch
thank you thank you so much
it was it was a gift i have to say was
really an amazing opportunity yeah i'm
curious if you were hesitant at all
about doing it was it something you
immediately wanted to do to work with
her or were you
nervous about it i was
um
no i mean i was i was actually
astounded that she wanted me to play
this because i know i mean it's been
really important for her to make her own
her own road and to have her own journey
and but i feel like she's feels secure
that she's already acknowledged herself
independently from me
and she was comfortable with the idea of
working with me i was relieved because
um especially for this role she knew
that i
i
i've had personal experiences with
mental illness because my mother was
diagnosed with schizophrenia right after
i was born and
had shot shock treatments and um
and then came home to be
really kind of left alone like they
didn't have the support system back then
it was an embarrassment to have any kind
of mental illness
so i grew up in this really crazy
environment and
margaret knew that she was like oh my
god i know i know who's perfect for this
you can do this
and it was a gift because i i don't
think anybody would have thought about
me to to play this because i've never
done it before and until you do
something people don't know you're
capable of doing it
and then um
from there i just fell in love with the
character i just loved everything about
my character and i
explored it physically and the whole
sexual side of her and i had no
hesitation hesitation or reservation
whether someone liked me or didn't like
me i always loved paula no matter what
she did
and that was just the way i came about
it and
i think we worked really well together
and then when i saw it i was blown away
by her performance because i think i was
so wrapped up in what i was doing i
wasn't really stopping to think about
about her performance but then i could
see
just i mean there were some things i was
conscious of but i you know i wasn't
there for everything
but i've got you know just a tenderness
and
how deep it is and how it comes from the
inside and and um
[Music]
pure there's an innocence and purity to
her work and i think
they it they're so opposite that it's
you know it's charismatic in the flat
and the complexity of just how different
these two people are
but they're but their blood
you know i just it's it was it's really
interesting
were there moments that you were really
glad that you had her there with you
that she was the one that you guys were
both sort of emotionally burying your
souls with
i felt like i
i felt like i understood how
paul how what my performance was going
to affect her performance i think i was
very conscious of that
i understood that
the
the
how if i showed just how
broken paula was if i could show if i
could you could see the darkness of
paula you could see
the
if i were did a better job it was going
to make everything better for her for
alex because then you could see what
alex had to deal with i was very
conscious of that and um but i didn't go
about it in a way that was terrifying or
anything like that i just went went
about it and i'm very joyful
uh just so i'm gonna eat this that's the
way i went about it was just i'm gonna
devour this character and i'm just going
to
get in there and just make this juicy
and that's kind of the way i went about
it
but i'm on the weekends i
helped take care of her so i felt like i
could serve her actually not never
another dimension was that i could
actually be a mother for her and i never
get to do that anymore because of course
she doesn't let me
but
i got to cook for her on the weekend and
that brought me a lot of
you know that's
cathartic
sorry
just chopping vegetables and yeah
cooking for someone nurturing someone
there's great beauty to that so i got to
do that on the weekends
this is a character who's described as
undiagnosed bipolar and since there
isn't really one way to play
bipolar right how did you
want to find the levels of her to make
it feel as authentic as possible did it
feel
was there a sense of freedom in
how you played her in any given moment
because there isn't really a standard to
go by
i'm very conscious of that because i've
had to deal with a lot of different
mental illness throughout my family
and i've read a lot and i've done a lot
of research and i've been in a lot of
therapy
um so yes it is very individual you
can't really compare one person to
another person and diagnosis are always
wrong a lot of times wrong not always
wrong sorry i said that wrong but
they're quite often wrong it's really
hard to find a diagnosis because it's so
complex and the mind you know i mean
it can seem like one thing one day and
one thing another day
but um
definitely uh the mania
was apparent and i think that's pretty
pure for
um
for bipolar uh the the mania the sort of
date the night not sleeping at night and
that you know was is pretty pure
um but on top of it she smokes so much
weed
that she is medicating in a sense i mean
she even admits that that is her
medicine so she's self-medicating with
um
marijuana that's how she balances
herself
oh just such an interesting character
yeah
how do you feel about where things are
left for her by the end of the season
and and between this mother and daughter
do you wish that things could have been
different between them do you feel like
she wouldn't have even been capable of
things being different at this point in
her life it was something that's not in
there that
i liked
that last scene was really a kind of
tough one to figure out but
it's not in there but i get in the back
of the car
and
i say to maddie
i say really quietly to maddie look you
take i tell her to take care of her
mother
so my hope was
that paula made the choice to let her
leave but you that he doesn't really you
don't really feel that so much because
that's not in there
but that was my hope only because i have
such empathy for my character i don't
think it was important or relevant for
alex and alex is the lead and the story
is about alex
but
i would have liked for that for people
to have known that was
paula's choice but now i'm thinking that
she's just choosing the man and that
she's you know
doing her thing again during her thing
again i think was more really more
important for alex's story
and alex is leaving you really do get a
sense of that all of it comes out of a
place of fear with her that even if she
doesn't realize it but it's not
something she's necessarily doing to
hurt
somebody else she just
is afraid and it's easy for her to
fall back on that
yeah i mean i think
it definitely
i mean there's mammoths like the moment
when i say get that baby out of here in
the hospital
it's pretty cruel
but she's in the middle of an episode so
what can you do and she's you know she's
in a that was the meanest thing i think
i did in the whole thing well i also go
off on her in the very beginning and
tell her she's flirting with my man that
was pretty cruel too
but i mean those do come from a place of
her illness you know i mean it's not
she's not in control she doesn't
she's completely out of control you know
she can't help what she's doing it's not
intentional if she had
better care
a better living situation
and she was on really good medicine and
getting therapy
you know i probably would be a better
mother and a better person
but that's not the situation
do you have your own hope for her that
they reunite in some way down the road
somewhere in their lives oh for sure
yes if we talked about that she goes
what do you think i was like no she's
going to come
she's going to come she's not going to
stay but she's going to come i said
she'll show up in a some kind of
winnebago she's gotta see her
granddaughter she's gonna come she won't
stay
but she'll come
well i appreciate you talking to me
about her this is really it's a fabulous
character you're terrific in this and
thank you for talking about it
thank you so much